Chris Shell Stauss has some Choice words
for the organizers of this year's
People's Choice Awards yes the selling
Sunset star is lasting the awards show
claiming she was not allowed to bring
her partner g-flip as her date
taking to Twitter with no filter after
the show Chris Shel admits I am on the
sauce a bit so I will probably regret
this later but People's Choice didn't
allow me to bring my partner to the
awards I could only bring a plus one if
it was a cast member
WTF krishelle was individually nominated
for best reality star in addition to
being nominated with her cast while
adding sure this means I will never be
nominated again but honestly F you she
also points out every single cast member
invited and some had plus ones I was
nominated for best reality star and yet
they said no again fu
several users online noted that
christelle's co-star Heather Ray almusa
attended the show with her husband HGTV
star tarek El Moussa who was not a
selling Sunset cast member and the
reality star continues her lengthy
thread noting that her partner is not in
the country and wouldn't have been able
to attend but krishelle insists that she
had been fighting to bring them
concluding her online rant chriselle
writes I get it there are way bigger
issues but these are the things people
normally don't say out loud unless they
have multiple correspondence receipts
and have had one too many Tequilas and
don't give an f now the couple first
went public with their romance back in
May following krishelle's split from
Jason oppenheim last December Chris
Shell confirms She's Dating the
non-binary Australian singer during the
selling Sunset reunion while explaining
they first connected after she starred
in g-flip's steamy music video for get
me out of here I recently have been
spending a lot of time with someone
that's very important to me their name
is Keith whip they're non-binary so they
go by they them okay
um and they are an extremely talented
musician and it started because you know
I was just going to be in their video
and it's about this Chaotic Love Story
and you know I come from Subs I love
acting and with the job that we have I
don't always get to do it and so at
first of course I was like yes let's do
that